we begin at a pivotal moment in the war
in Ukraine Charlie dagada has been
traveling in that part of the country
following an ever-shifting front line
which has lately been moving in the
ukrainian's favor the red area on this
map is the territory once held by Russia
including areas it claims to have
legally annexed and this is what Ukraine
has managed to take back in just the
past few weeks including the
strategically important city of Lehman
Charlie was able to reach that City
where locals say it was a bitter victory
good morning ever since President Putin
announced the illegal annexation of this
region Ukraine's military offensive has
only accelerated here in the East and in
the South while Russia's retaliation
continues to unleash heavy weapons on
civilian targets we should warn you this
report contains some disturbing images
overnight seven Rockets slammed into
this residential neighborhood in
zapparesia turning apartment blocks into
an inferno as they continue to lose
ground Russian forces go to the air with
long-range weapons
the Crane's military machine is on the
war path
pushing South toward Kershaw
falling back more territory than ever in
the Eastern donbass region
where the road to the newly liberated
city of Lehman shows the sheer
destruction from The Savage tug of war
here
this whole area Bears the scars of a
region that's been fought over for
months now again under Ukrainian
military control but liberated at a cost
closer still the human costs a bombed
out Convoy and we were told the
belongings of Russian soldiers who were
trying to flee their bodies still in the
woods also left behind anti-tank mines
more dangerous are the ones you can't
see we finally reached the city center
Ukrainian flag flying high for the first
time in months residents who rode out
the storm emerged from basement shelters
to receive a loaf of bread or two from
Aid workers
yeah there was so much shelling I stayed
in the basement says sveta my husband is
disabled so I was taking care of him but
the fight to free this city from Russian
occupation has left it in tatters most
of the world sees this as a great
Victory but you don't see it that way
Victory oh God it's a dead City Nadia
told us where is the victory they
destroyed the city and that's it
there is no running water no electricity
no heat for their homes with Ukraine's
brutal winter fast closing in
and we had to leave after dark and most
of the donbass region including here has
blackout rules because of the fighting
but we drove for well over an hour from
Lehman before we caught the first
glimpse of homes with electricity for
CBS mornings Charlie dagada pakrofsk
Ukraine